hasta aquí probablemente me has
escuchado pronunciar sql de dos maneras
si cuenta o esquivel algunos de ustedes
incluso podrían estar molestos de que lo
pronuncia de una u otra manera y
probablemente tengas una muy buena razón
para creer que la pronunciación que
prefieres es la correcta entonces cuál
es el problema bueno
sql fue inventado originalmente en ibm a
principios de los años 70 y la primera
versión fue llamada sql que significa
estructura inglés query language
lenguaje inglés estructurado de consulta
el acrónimo seawell fue cambiado más
tarde por esquivel porque es igual ya
era una marca registrada de una compañía
aérea y a las compañías no les gusta
tener líos legales de marcas registradas
en la actualidad muchos de nosotros
seguimos pronunciando seawell porque es
una manera más corta de decirlo y
tenemos razones históricas para afirmar
que es la manera correcta sin embargo
cuando pregunto a desarrolladores de
todo el mundo encuentro que en otros
idiomas muchos pronuncian esquivel
o por ejemplo en español pronuncian sql
como nuestros vídeos de khan academy
están siendo traducidos me imagino que
es más fácil para los traductores
escuchar la pronunciación es cruel la
forma larga
pero en el día a día estoy acostumbrada
a decir si huele así que podría decirlo
de las dos maneras
ahora ya saben puede ser escuela o si
huele y probablemente escuchen las dos
formas por el resto de sus vidas el
mundo es un lugar desordenado pero al
menos ahora tienen una forma de hacer
preguntas estructuradas cierto